[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
taking a look at the English opening and
English opening is a little bit
different in then the openings we've
been taking a look at and it's actually
the first flank opening that we're gonna
take a look at and I'll go over that
here English opening starts out pawn to
c4 and this is a flank opening basically
meaning that you are attacking the
center using pieces from the outside so
instead of moving thrusting forward with
d4 or efore you're trying to stake
Center control with your C pawn this is
this gets into kind of a hyper modern
type of opening meaning that you're
going to attack with your minor pieces
instead of using the pawns at the
beginning but right off the bat white
basically stakes claim to this a d5
square very important square and any
opening to control the center and why
it's basically saying that I want to
control the light squares
I'm obviously on black side the two
Center squares they did light square in
the dark square and why it says that he
wants to control the light square so
eventually some of the common themes
that you'll see why doing the English
opening as you will fee and cheto his
Bishop to the King side so that his
light square bishop is actually giving
more support to the d5 square kind of
the hyper modern opening that we talked
about attacking with your minor pieces
and then once the center is fortified
and attacked by all the minor pieces
then we start to thrust forward with our
our pawns on the D and E file
so from here black can continue in many
variations a lot of times you'll see
there a five or g6e five is usually the
most common as black tries to gain
center control and he black has
basically said that I want to try to
control the dark squares here with his
pawn and from here we're going to put
more pressure on the light squares and
we're going to develop our knight again
this is a very strong opening here we
have Center control on the d5 Square and
we still have still have a lot that we
can do as far as later on bringing our
pawns into the game and figuring out
what blacks trying to do and counter
that so from here black usually will
develop his Knight to f6 and here we're
going to the mainline we're gonna go
ahead and start to fianchetto our bishop
and the reason is you always don't want
to Finch out of your bishop unless you
have a good reason to but we do have a
very good reason here we want to
solidify this d5 square and we already
have this pawn defending and this Knight
defending and so our bishop here will
develop our bishop along this diagonal
and give another defender to the d5
square so we are first going to
bring our pawn to g3 and then black can
decide a lot of times you will see
simply a c6 move or you also may see
black fianchetto on his King side as
well both lines kind of the same concept
but we'll go ahead and just take a look
if he develops his knight we're going to
go ahead and finch head o our bishop
here as you see that we've talked about
we have lots of pressure on this d5
square and eventually we can develop our
Knight to f3 and put pressure on the
pawn here that black has on the e5
square and eventually we can bring our
pawn into the action and then we can
develop our bishop
many times you will Castle kingside with
the fin shadow bishop keep in mind that
when you fianchetto your bishop that
bishop now becomes very important so
this light square bishop although it
always is very important the light
square bishop for white when you Finch
head oh it's even more important so you
definitely don't want to sacrifice a lot
of common mistakes people will
fianchetto because they think they're
supposed to and then they will sacrifice
for a knight and basically you're just
opening your King up when you don't have
to so only use this bishop that you
fianchetto in this case the light square
bishop if you have good reason to he has
a long diagonal that he can attack on
but keep him safe if you can at the
beginning obviously later on when the
attack starts to develop in the middle
you can
figure out what you need to do best then
but for the time being go ahead and keep
him back there are many different
variations of the English opening but
just want to kind of give you a few of
the key concept as far as starting out
we'll do some follow-up videos as far as
some other variations but hope you guys
enjoy the English opening I hope you
kind of have a feel for how you should
approach it and please subscribe to the
videos have a lot more coming out hope
you enjoyed and see y'all next video